-Welcome back to "The Tonight
Show," everybody.
It's time to play a game called
"Search Party."
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Oh, yes!
♪♪
-[ Electronic voice ]
"Search Party."
-Oh! Playing tonight, we have
the cohosts of "Queer Eye" --
Jonathan Van Ness,
Antoni Porowski,
Tan France, and Bobby Berk!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yes!
-Thanks.
Thank you.
-Whoo!
-And their opponents...
-The winners.
-Jimmy Fallon, J.B. Smoove,
Questlove, and the James Poyser!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Rimshot ]
[ Laughter ]
Okay! First up.
Oh, there you go.
Nice, nice, yeah,
little, yeah, nice shot.
-I'm so nervous.
-Okay, first up,
Jimmy and Jonathan.
Come on up.
-Oh, my God.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-OM.
-I'm so nervous.
-Oh, my God.
-Here's how the game works.
-Yeah.
-I will read you the start
of an Internet search question
and you will fill in the blank.
-OK.
-You'll both type in
your answers as fast as you can
-Oh, my God.
-and then, we'll match them,
to see if any of them go
with the top 3, okay?
Okay, here's the first search.
♪♪
-Keep it clean.
-Ready, type in the answers.
[ Laughter ]
-[ Laughing ] No, Jonny!
-Aw, Jonny.
-Okay, Jimmy,
what did you write?
[ Laughter ]
-I wrote...
-Kiss.
-Jonathan, what did you write?
Have sex.
-Do we have any matches?
[ Cheering and applause ]
-There you go.
-Kiss!
-Oh, no!
-Come on, let's go, okay!
-Nice.
-[ Laughs ]
-It's okay.
[ Voices overlapping ]
It's okay.
-Okay, J.B.
-Yes.
-On a first date,
should you blank?
-Mm!
-What's your answer?
-Two more.
-Two more spots.
-I know what it is.
-Go Dutch.
-Go Dutch! Let's see go Dutch!
-Whoo!
-That's what I would pick.
-Go Dutch?
-That's a good one.
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Yeah!
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Oh, no!
-I was shocked!
-That was good.
-You know how many dates
I went on?
You know how many dates I've
been on before I got married?
Come on, man!
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, no!
-Okay, Quest.
-Go to dinner?
-Yeah.
-Go to dinner.
Let's say go to dinner.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
[ Audience ohs ]
-No results.
-You guys can steal.
What do you say?
-Aah!
-Get together.
Give us an answer.
-Pressure.
-Get together, everyone.
-Pressure's on.
-Come on, come on, come on.
-What is it?
-Between kiss and pay...
-Be hot.
-No, no, no.
-What is it? What is it?
What is it? Come on, come on.
-What do you think?
What do you think?
-Hard kiss.
-Handy!
Like handsy -- handies.
-A handy.
-Handy.
-Not a handy.
[ Laughter ]
-It's not a handy!
It's not that!
-It's a family show.
-You can't say that.
-Can't say that.
-It's not that.
-You can't say any
of those words.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-You guys have an answer?
-Talk about their exes.
-Let's see talk about your exes.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
-You win.
-We win! We win! We won.
We won, baby.
We win! We win!
-What was it?
-Let's see
what the last answer was.
♪♪
[ All ohing ]
-Awful.
Awful people.
Okay, time for Round 2.
J.B. and Antoni, you're up.
Let's go.
♪♪
-Antoni, come up here.
Get ready to type in.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Get ready to type in
your answers.
-I got this. I got this.
I'm feeling good.
-Alright.
-You too good?
-I feel good.
-Complete this search question.
♪♪
-Yeah.
-Type it in as fast as you can.
-Tan, don't say anything.
-Lock it.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Lock it in.
-That's a good guess.
-Oh, yeah.
-Okay.
-Antoni, what did you write?
-What's wrong with my child?
[ Laughter ]
-Child?
[ Applause ]
[ Voices overlapping ]
-I literally Googled that
last week.
-J.B., what did you write?
-And I write,
"What's wrong with my mind?"
-Mind.
-People say that all the time.
"What am I doing?
What am I doing?
What's wrong with my mind?"
-[ Laughs ]
Let's see if that's right.
-Let's see.
-Let's see if there's a match.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, no!
Okay, Antoni,
since you buzzed in first...
-Yep.
-...you get to guess again.
-Get to guess again.
-Can we help?
-Do I type it or do I say it?
-I think you just say it.
-I just say it.
-Can we help?
-Live it up.
-What's wrong with my car?!
-Yes.
-Let's see car!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-Car!
[ Cheering and applause ]
-Okay.
-Go back over there.
-Yes! Yes! Yes!
-Okay, Tan.
-Yeah.
-We needed that, America.
We needed that win!
-Yeah.
-What's wrong with my blank?
What's your answer?
-What's wrong with my skin?
-Skin.
-Good.
-Uh-oh.
-Good answer.
-Yeah!
-Let's see skin.
I bet that's up there.
[ Buzzer ]
-Come on!
-No, it's not.
-Good answer.
-I could've done that
-Bobby.
-sound effect for you.
-Health.
What's wrong with my health?
-Let's see health!
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh!
Chance to steal.
-Uh-oh.
-Guys got to huddle.
Chance to steal.
-I think it's phone.
-Phone?
Alright, Quest says phone.
James says wife.
-Oh!
-I say phone.
-Phone?
-Phone.
-Let's see phone!
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]
-No!
-There we go.
-We got the win.
We got the win on that one.
-Got the win on that one.
-Let's see what
that last answer was.
-Oh!
-Dog.
-I should've known!
-Oh, my God.
-You had it.
You had it.
And they did not listen.
Okay!
This is the final round.
-Oh, I'm nervous.
-The game -- Questlove, Tan,
you're up. Come on up.
-Let's do it.
-[ Chanting ] Tanny! Tanny!
-Let's go.
Tanny! Tanny!
-There we go.
-You'll win. You'll win.
-Thank you.
-Okay, ready?
-[Both] Yes.
-Okay, name a word
that completes
this Internet search.
-Okay.
♪♪
[ Laughter ]
-Oh, my God.
-Mm!
-Oh, wait.
Let's say bippy.
-Hey, Tan, Tan.
[ Laughter ]
-Yeah.
-Too specific!
-Yeah, I think that works.
-Yeah.
[ Laughter ]
-Is everybody blocked in?
-Mm-hmm.
-Press Enter, the green button.
-Oh, you have to press --
Oh, there you go.
-Sorry.
-Okay.
Question, what did you write?
You buzzed in first.
-As a person with experience,
I would say the answer is hair.
-Hair!
Okay, Tan, what did you say?
-That felt too obvious for me,
so I thought ears.
[ Laughter and applause ]
-Ears.
-I hate people touching my ears
and my neck, so, yeah.
-Really?
-Ears.
-Let's see ears and hair.
♪♪
-Yeah, Quest!
[ Cheering ]
-Okay, get back over there.
-We got this.
We got this.
-Okay, back to you, Jimmy.
Back to you.
Got one more strike.
-Hand?
No. Music?
Touch their...stuff?
Stuff.
-Stuff?
-Stuff.
-Let's see stuff!
-Oh, come on.
[ Buzzer ]
-Oh, okay!
You guys get a chance to steal.
-Yes.
-The question is obviously
do you like their...
but we can't say it, okay?
[ Laughter and applause ]
-No, no, no, no.
-Like what's --
-Okay.
-It's "Do guys like it,"
not "Guys like it."
-What about butt?
That's what I said, butt.
-[ Chanting ] Butt, butt, butt,
butt, butt!
-I don't think that's allowed.
He said it's a TV --
-No.
Butt's fine.
-Because like Netflix,
we can say butt.
-We can say whatever.
[ Laughter ]
-Touch their...?
-Butt.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Is butt your final answer?
-Yeah.
-Yeah!
-Let's see butt!
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Buzzer ]
Oh!
Let's see what they were.
Let's see the answers.
-What are you Googling?!
♪♪
-Next one.
-Oh!
-I said face!
-We got the winners over here.
-I said face.
[ Applause ]
-You said ears.
-Judges, judges.
[ Voices overlapping ]
-Ear is a part of your face!
-Ears!
[ Buzzer ]
-It's right off of your face.
-I'll deal with you
after the show.
-[ Laughs ]
[ Cheering and applause ]
My thanks -- We won!
-[ Cheering ]
[ Rimshot ]
-My thanks to the cohosts
of "Queer Eye."
Season 6 is streaming now
on Netflix.
Thanks to J.B. Smoove.
"Spider-Man: No Way Home" is
in theaters now.